well hello there you're watching the
press preview a first look at what is on
the front pages
coming up then we'll see what's making
the headlines with the columnist carol
malone and the liverpool echoes
political editor liam thorpe as ever
great to see you
from patreon according to the telegraph
the chancellor
rishi sunak is encouraging people to
return
to the office when work for home rules
change on july the 19th
the metro looks ahead to england's
appearance in the euros final on sunday
declaring
it's the final countdown fever pitch
says the mirror as fans call for a bank
holiday monday
if england win with its tongue firmly in
cheek over england's italian opponents
the star
asks what have the romans ever done for
us and then lists many things they have
done for us
the guardian leads with the relaxing of
quarantine rules and how 100 countries
will soon be open for makers from
england to visit once again the daily
mail leading on the covet 19
app and how a redesign could spare
thousands
from isolation whereas the express leads
on rishi sunak's pensions promise and
how a pension rise could be under threat
the times leads with possible plans
within whitehall
and how some families could receive a
payout to offset
green energy bills while the financial
times reporting that the european
central bank has set an inflation target
of
two percent to try to allow governments
to keep interest
rates low so carol malone and liam
thought liam better kick off for you i
think you've just recovered or maybe you
still haven't who knows um
but quite a night and another one to
look forward to
yeah um a little bit of a sore head
today i'm sure i wasn't the only one
um after after obviously a real sort of
nail biter
of a match last night i just think that
at this time in in the country when
obviously
like like other countries you know
people have been through so much it is
just so nice to have
something to to celebrate and i think
this team particularly and you know it's
a team full of young
um really sort of decent young men who
are you know who are
you know not afraid to stand up for what
they believe in they're an exciting
young bunch of players and
let's be honest they're led by a a
really decent fellow in
southgate who i think everyone is now
sort of turning to to kind of lead the
nation
um and yeah i think it's just a it's an
amazing kind of
collective moment which we probably
haven't had in in this country for a
while maybe since the uh since 2012
and it feels like you know there is a
kind of collective spirit and people
just feeling like they can actually
celebrate something after such a tough
time
so bring it on i think they've done you
know i think they've done everything
they can and it's going to be really
really tough game
on sunday but i think they've already
made a huge success of it
yes it's interesting you related to the
london olympics
in 2012 when we've had the news of the
tokyo olympics today but perhaps we'll
we'll come on to that and certainly we
had steve mclaren on today who is
middlesborough manager uh when gareth
southgate was captain there
and said he led by example he was first
in you know he always
celebrated calmly as we have seen him
done now but leading from the front do
you reckon
uh carol how much can be attributed to
him
oh i think yeah yeah a huge amount can
be attributed to him
i mean i you know everyone i mean you
know what i know about football could be
written on the back of a football
er but but the bottom line is i was
listening to all the the
pundits last night and they're just
saying that this guy is the first guy in
many many years
to pull the team together that they
looked like a very confident team
last night whereas in in past years they
haven't they've gone on kind of
expecting to lose
and just to listen to the team and all
the the run up to the matches
they didn't expect to lose this year
they expected to win
and they have and and i think liam put
his swing on it they know
gareth sags gate is a really lovely
fella and i think
you know he is respected because of that
he's respected because of his talent
and his ability to make people work
together and you know i mean i was kind
of
watching it last night i missed the
first half because i was on a motorway
trying to get back from somewhere
the motorway by the way which was
totally empty
it was the best run i've ever had
because everyone was watching the footy
and it was just really edge of your seat
stuff you know i mean i was kind of
you know i'm not a big football fan i
wanted england to win but once you start
watching it's like
they had a sweating right until the very
end
and and then of course there's all the
the controversy today
about schmeichel having this laser thing
shown
in his eyeball which which kind of
taints i think this
incredible event because have you
everyone is talking about that today
your wayfarer
has has laid a charge against um the
the uh against england for this and i
and i just think it's such a shame
because you know
we should just be talking about the wind
and not
this kind of tainted thing where
that the goalkeeper may have been
distracted by this laser which is like
you know they if they're they're a
menace and they've been used in lots of
sports and there was a guy
james last year who used one on an
aircraft they're very dangerous things
yeah but it's just a shame it had to
happen on the back of this
yeah i mean most most people have you
know completely reiterated that today
too but it was the booze as well wasn't
it
liam fireworks in the ground even the
pictures on the front page of the daily
mirror
you know fans climbing on a double
decker bus which is all high jinks and
enthusiasm no doubt but
there was certainly some police down
there to try and prevent that a bit
later on but do you think do you think
the fa needs to come out and say
you know let's play fair let's play
nicely and let's
you know be well behaved now i think so
yeah i mean
there's always a number of people who
you know will try and kind of ruin it
for everyone else i have to say i find
that the booing of of
our own players and the booing of um
opposition's national anthems
utterly deplorable you know this is a
supposed to be a game of respect where
everyone respects one another um
you know so i i i really found that
difficult um and and
there's just no need for it at all you
know we should be getting behind
yes our team we should be treating the
other team with total respect as well
and the shining of the laser pen is as
as carol says it just miles things a bit
you know we've heard some reports of
of um danish fans being um abused as
well
and and it's just it's just disgraceful
really when as
always are you optimistic and positive
that there has to be
yes i talked to of you because you
briefly froze but you're back um
yeah the metro talks about the final
countdown in fact the mirror also talks
about
millions millions of fans to make it a
three billion pound
biggest party weekend ever it does feel
like for many
the pandemic is over despite the raising
rising cases
carol um is it just a sign that people
have had enough for what
i i think i think they have yeah and i
mean there is no question that the
the infection character is going to go
up next week i mean i read a story today
saying
there's lots more men becoming infected
now than women and they think it's
because of the football because a lot of
men have gone to the games
um you know and there will undoubtedly
be more infections next week and
there'll be people asking
is it you know was it worth it you know
is is football more important than
than covert infections and i think a lot
of people in this country
currently would say yes it is um and
as we saw last night no one was wearing
a mask no one was social distancing
that's probably because of the amount of
booze that was taken but you know
you can see why some people might be a
bit hacked off at this where
you know you can't go to see your kids
at this school sports day you can't you
can't
have um too many people going to visit
somewhere a relative
at a care home but you can have
thousands and thousands lining our
streets in the capital city
without protection so you can see why
some people might be upset at that
yes um perhaps less the games and more
the the meet-ups
the gatherings to to watch the match
which obviously will continue
um daily star you've picked two what
have the romans ever done for us
and it proves to be quite a long list as
we said i was just thinking pizza but oh
no
aqueducts sanitation roads irrigation i
mean the romans obviously they
you know had a major impact did they not
um but
uh it just shows they're gonna be tough
they're they're unbroken record
of wins is is is slightly daunting isn't
it liam
yeah i think it's is it 43 now i think
and of course they didn't qualify for
the
well but um manchini the manager has
really
pulled off something of a miracle the
way that he's turned that side around
and i think there's some similarities
when you look at england and the
italians
it's they they as carol's before they
really are a team who are all playing
for each other
and there's not loads of kind of egos in
there which which have been in the case
with both italy and england before
this is a young team that are really
playing for each other so i i i don't
think england favorites going into it
and i think it's a it should be a
brilliant game um but as i said before i
think i think
what southgate and his team have done
already is enough to kind of really
boost the country
and it's at home isn't it um we know
about home games
um everyone talks about euro 96 but also
1966
which sort of has loomed over all of us
um for years of football watching
you know more of a more of a nightmare
and a joyous thing you know it's a sort
of shackle to get rid of rid of and
and really people need to talk about
something else don't they carol now
that's what that's one reason to win but
i kind of i kind of worry what's going
to happen on monday if we lose you know
this kind of further
this kind of excitement we haven't seen
in this country for a very long time
and i kind of worry a bit you know i
mean and i want i don't think boris is
going to give us a bank holiday because
he actually said today he didn't want to
jinx it by making
it a bank holiday and he's just certain
employers would be a little bit you know
relax and
a lot of employers and i was saying
people can come in two or three hours
late
but what is the level of disappointment
going to be we saw the level
of excitement yesterday what's it going
to be like if we lose on sunday man it's
going to be
it's going to be worse than it would
normally be if we lost something because
this seems to be about so much more than
football it's a kind of release for
everyone
and i kind of worry about what's going
to happen on on sunday if we lose
yes uh what is it 287 000 people have
now signed
uh that petition asking for let's see
frozen
hello liam oh he's going how's he going
i can't tell he's so still that's
because he's a little [ __ ] you know
that's really bad news because he's the
only one that knows what he's talking
about here
well that's really bad luckily we're
going to break and we could talk about
other matters anyway 287 000 people have
signed this petition
carol uh asking for that holiday but as
you said the prime minister very
unlikely to jinx it indeed so yeah
yes i mean we won't get it nor should we
really
but if people have got a bank holiday
and they're upset and disappointed
imagine what's going to happen
on monday if people got the whole day to
get cross
doesn't bear thinking about well we know
liam
told us earlier he's already booked a
half day he is either optimistic or uh
or just hopeful we will we'll find out
when he comes back
let's see now we can he looks a bit
rough actually he looks hungover
we can talk about him now we haven't got
him poor lat yeah
we'll see you later liam too um coming
up though changes are coming to
self-isolation rules but is the app
too sensitive we'll discuss that next
[Music]
well welcome back you're watching the
press preview with me now carol malone
and liam thought welcome back to both of
you
um so question we have rising cases that
means more people
are pinged which means eventually if
cases continue to rise
many people will not be at work q what
do you do about it
liam daily mail thousands are spared
isolation madness
what are they suggesting so
we saw rishi sunak actually today
speaking in the media saying that
what they are looking at is a sort of
refinement of the kobit app
which would take into account for
example that people have been double
vaccinated
which wouldn't be i think they said as
as cent so you wouldn't have quite as
many people
being pinged and because there was one
prediction that it could be up to three
and a half million people because of
obviously the rates are still soaring
and so the government is keen to avoid
the massive disruption that that will
cause obviously there's a bit of a kind
of chaotic element to this because
this isn't going to happen until
mid-august and obviously
when when some of the rules are changing
in uh july the 19th so what you are
seeing is people
which is not being advised of course is
they're just turning the app off because
they don't want to get pinged
because obviously it could have a huge
impact as well on people's working lives
on the nhs itself and so yeah they're
gonna look at
ways to refine the app but i don't think
it's gonna happen straight away yes in
our deputy political editor sam coats
reporting tonight that there is
apparently modelling under the previous
health secretary
which shows at this level basic things
start to falter the transportation
network the health service for example
with the numbers of people who are going
off but but carol why do we
think about fiddling with the app and
making it less sensitive
rather than fiddling with the policy and
suggesting rising cases is not
necessarily a good thing for this
country
well because the app says you have to
isolate for 10 days and
and very often it's it's healthy people
with no symptoms
who've been double jabs who are
isolating for 10 days which is the
nonsense
you know currently the nhs has a fifth
of its entire staff off who are
isolating you know currently
you know before what's something yeah we
could have up we can have a million
people
isolating at home just now it's crazy
we've got
kids have missed a billion days at
school with isolating needlessly
it's crazy and you know people are
deleting their apps
the story in the papers today saying
that even nhs
staff are deleting their apps because
they don't want to be off work
and and and there's there's a there's a
move to have doctors and nurses
exempted from that from isolation even
until august the 16th
all together because you know these guys
can be
a lot of these guys have already had it
that double jab they can be tested in
hospital
why send them home for 10 days when when
hospitals are crippled not with covert
patients but with just
lack of staff it's crazy test and
release is what some people are
suggesting would be
would be better a bit more like like the
travel arrangements which takes us
inside the
the metro um this is dido harding
defending
um what this paper quotes is the
successful 37 billion pound test and
trace
program many people of course think it's
just tracing and forget the huge cost of
our
testing program 1.2 million tests
carried out yesterday alone
on new coronavirus cases um what is what
is the defense then do you think for
this
for this money is it the huge number 217
million tests in total that
uh the uk has now carried out
but if you're not if you're not you're
not trading the contacts once you've
done the tests
then it sort of defies the point of it i
thought it was interesting that
daddy harding is probably the only
person who who could hail this uh
you know complete failure in my opinion
the test and trace system as a success
and i think there'll be quite a few
people sort of scoffing at her comments
to the select committee look 37 billion
pounds i think it's widely regarded as
as
a failure and it has been heavily
criticized for not
curtailing um the spread of the virus
which is exactly what it was designed to
do
the number of contacts that have been
missed is massive and as i say
it's all yes there is one section to it
which is a massive cost for the testing
process which by the way was was failing
at the start but once you get that up
and running if you're not then
tracing the contacts successfully then
it decides the point
but i suppose in defense of the system
who knows how public health england with
its
nice local knocking on doors would have
scaled up
with the number of cases we've seen in
the various waves that we have had
um carol will never know that i guess
no we no we but can i just i'd like to
chip in on died over into i mean this
woman today
sat there and said she was proud of the
work
quickly sorry quickly
oh [ __ ] she's had catastrophic failures
in the private and public sector
and we should be really scared because
she now wants to be head of the nhs
god the fact that the fact that she's
being considered is terrifying
at the time of a global pandemic